[Music]
6 25 on your Monday morning what's
driving you crazy we've got kind of a
Jerry Seinfeld kind of question about
the ongoing road work and the spaghetti
Bowl now a viewer Andrew didn't come
right and ask well what's the deal
but he did say last three weeks or so
I've seen construction equipment parked
off to the right side of the 15 at the
on-ramp for the 95. I want an
explanation of the overnight work from
there up to Lake Mead well Andrew this
is the project that Canon has wreaked
havoc on the early rush hour drive north
on the 15. the northbounders you're down
to just one lane the explanation of the
work from the Nevada Department of
transportation's Justin Hopkins who
writes crews are Paving the shoulder and
outside Lane of the freeway between the
spaghetti wall and Craig Road requiring
several weeks of overnight lane closures
from 9 pm to 5 each following morning
now sometimes they get you back to two
or three lanes before 5 a.m but
sometimes not until closer to 5 30 this
morning it was right around five so
Andrew that's what all that equipment is
thanks for riding in buckle up drive
carefully please put on that phone and
you can join the driving you crazy
conversation traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com